I still love him and he's a very good
friend and that's why I was so shocked
by it because not only was it a fib but
it was so unlike him Mandy Moore opening
up about ex-boyfriend wailmer Valderrama
during an appearance on Sirius XM's of
the Howard Stern Show she set the record
straight on this intimate claim the 38
year old actor previously made he said I
took my virginity
he took your virginity and he did not he
did not he did not
oh I dated him when I was 16 and 17 no
it's one of the many things we learned
from Mandy's interview she also revealed
that Justin Timberlake recently called
to apologize and here's why he looked
down at my feet and was like oh you got
big feet for a girl of course the
incident happened years ago when a 15
year old mandy was on tour with insane
he's apologizing so he's such a lovely
guy
Meowth he was like I just want you to
know that i reaiiy had no idea what i
was saying i was probably trying to
flirt with you and i understand how
words can have an impact
these days it's Mandy's fiance DAWs
frontmen Taylor Goldsmith who's doing
the flirting she dropped these beats
about the couple's very first date we
had this epic like three hour long
dinner where we just didn't stop talking
and then he left to go on tour the next
day and we didn't see tweet we just
emailed and texted and face times back
and forth for like six weeks until we
could see each other again and no
romance on the first date in terms of
pho not even like holding hands nothing
I started to absolutely fall in love
with him just by communicating which was
the best dr. Milo Ventimiglia here's how
Mandy says she scored the role of his
wife Rebecca Pierson so I go into this
chemistry Reap they brought me in to
read with Milo and you know you don't
know the person you shake hands near
like hey you're gonna be my husband now
like knows
into my neck and let's pretend to be in
love and about to be birthing three
children like him and I it was instant
it was easy it was effortless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]